we may have rachel reeves and thank you
very much for uh being with us we just
heard
from rishi sunak who was saying i hope
you could hear me rachel reeves
hello excellent good news so we just
heard from rishi sunak the chancellor
effectively saying that things are going
to get difficult
and that he is not going to be able to
help or fully mitigate the cost of
living
crisis and
what do you make of what he had to say
well wednesday is an historic moment for
the chancellor for him to show whether
he really understands the challenges
that people are facing at the moment
because
as a constituency mp in leeds west i've
got mums who are saying to me
i'm struggling to put food on the table
i'm now skipping meals so i can feed my
children properly i've got pensioners
saying to me
i'm not turning the heating on even
though i need to because i'm worried
about how i'm going to pay the bills and
for those people and millions of others
up and down the country
we need more than warm words from the
chancellor we need the chancellor to do
the things that will relieve that
pressure on the cost of living like a
windfall tax on the big profits being
made by north sea oil and gas companies
and channel that back into lower prices
for everybody else and as for the
increase in national insurance
contributions it's the wrong tax at the
wrong time that's going to take even
more money out of the purses and wallets
of working people
well let's talk about the uh plaid rise
national insurance and we just had the
chance of defending it effectively
saying that he needs to sort out
long-term funding for the nhs and social
care and that is specifically what that
tax is designed to do it feels like i'm
in some kind of parallel universe where
labour is arguing against a tax rise for
the nhs what's going on
well originally you'll remember sophie
the the chancellor and prime minister
said that the national insurance
contribution rise was to fix the social
care problem but we now know that
there's going to be no new money for
social care in this parliament then they
said it was to reduce nhs waiting times
but there's no credible plan to do that
in this parliament
and all the while we know that the
government are wasting billions of
pounds of taxpayers money just in the
last few days we've heard shocking
stories that 8.7 billion pounds
overspent in ppe procurement including
ppe that couldn't even be used by the
nhs and now the government are burning
it taxpayers money literally going up in
flames so you can't help wondering
whether this tax rise is to pay for a
black hole because of this government's
waste and mismanagement well either way
if there is a black hole in the nhs
doesn't it need to be filled for
whatever the reason is
in which case why national insurance
because the problem with national
insurance is that is a tax on work it's
a tax charge by those people who go out
to work every day and those people who
employ them some of the richest people
in our country who earn an income
through uh dealing in stocks and shares
or through a portfolio of buy to let
properties
they won't pay a penny more in tax with
the national insurance rise
that's not right it's not right that
ordinary working people should be
fitting the bill and we are the only g7
economy that is increasing taxes
taxes would you like to need every penny
what other taxes would you like to see
increase
or do you think the tax burden is too
high well first
first of all sophie i think that this is
the wrong tax at the wrong time and in
the middle of a cost of living crisis we
shouldn't be increasing taxes you know
the chancellor keeps giving interviews
and speeches saying that he's a low tax
chancellor will prove it on wednesday
reverse this national insurance
contributions rights and cut vat on
domestic gas and electricity bills to
help people with the cost of living
crisis now look i know that chancellors
have to make difficult decisions you've
got to account for every penny of
taxpayers money spent but if you are
going to increase taxes you should ask
people with the broader shoulders to
make a
bigger contribution this chancellor is
not doing this with the national
insurance increase rise and that's why i
say it's the wrong tax at the wrong time
do you think rishi sunak should cut fuel
duty
so i didn't hear that question sophie
should rishi sinak cut fuel duty
if the chancellor inc reduces fuel duty
this week we won't stand in his way but
even a 5p reduction in fuel duty will
only reduce filling up the car with
petrol by two pounds so i don't think
that really rises to the scale of the
challenge that we face at the moment
which is why we're calling for a
windfall tax on the big profits being
made by north sea oil and gas companies
right now and channel that in
with both a reduction in vat from 5 to 0
on gas and electricity bills but also a
big expansion in the warm homes discount
because we know it is families and
pensioners on low and modest incomes who
are struggling most at the moment with
the rising prices so that would be my
priority for any sensible measures to
deal with the cost of living crisis of
course labour would support those on
wednesday i just want to talk a bit
about the windfall tax because this is
something that labour is talking about a
lot you clearly feel that there's a
public polling to back you up but isn't
there a real risk that this could
discourage investment in the north sea
at a time when frankly we do need to
focus on our own domestic energy supply
because we're trying to cut ties with
places like
russia and independence and our
dependence on
places like russia for oil and gas
well when shell and bp announced their
record profits earlier this year at the
same time they announced a big increase
in the dividend payments and also share
buyback schemes they didn't announce big
future investment programs future
investment but this is the point but
this is exactly the point sophie with
the big profits they're making at the
moment they're not channeling that into
new investment instead they are using
that money to further push up their
share prices and we've also seen big
bonuses for the executives at these
companies so it's not clear to me
that these profits are being channeled
into investment but instead into further
inflating the share price when i first
said that there should be a win for tax
back in january we thought it would
raise about 1.2 billion pounds but since
then oil and gas prices have increased
substantially and that surcharge that
windfall tax would now bring in about
3.7 billion pounds and the chancellor
says that money somehow is untouchable
but the fact is chancellors have to make
choices about who to tax and who to
spare and instead of
carrying on down the path that this
chancellor is going on he should look
again at labour's proposals for a
windfall tax and use that to keep bills
low for everybody else that would be my
priority as a chancellor i'm deeply
disappointed it doesn't seem to be this
chancellor's priority
um i just want to talk to you about a
couple of things that the child that the
prime minister said yesterday at the
concept of spring conference
um we played the clip of him speaking to
rishi sinak earlier but just to read you
his words he said the people of this
country like the people of ukraine
choose freedom every time i can give you
a couple of famous recent examples when
the british people voted for brexit in
such large large numbers i don't believe
it was because they were remotely
hostile to foreigners it's because they
wanted to be free to do things
differently and for this country to be
able to run itself now rishi sudak
defended the prime minister he said that
he wasn't trying to make a comparison
it's not directly analogous he said and
the prime minister wouldn't say that
either what's your take on what the
prime minister said
it is utterly distasteful and insulting
to compare
the fight for freedom
and
the
aggression of the russian
state
to the decision to leave the european
union it is insulting to the ukrainian
people who are fighting for their very
freedom and their very lives and it's
insulting to the british people as well
and if the prime minister didn't mean
that analogy he shouldn't have made it
and he should take those back those
words and apologize to the ukrainian
people and the british people for those
crass remarks he made yesterday
uh rishi sunak also made the point that
the uk has been really supporting
ukraine
and the president zelensky uh has been
very grateful uh for the support that
the prime minister has given him and in
the same speech boris johnson said this
about labor
do we want them in charge at this moment
do we want them running up the white
flag do you see them standing up to
putin's blackmail what do you make of
that
well i'm not going to take any lessons
from this prime minister about standing
up to the russians this is a prime
minister who on the eve of the invasion
of ukraine was whining and dining people
were close links to putin's regime this
is a prime minister who overruled
security service in giving a peerage to
now lord lebedev of siberia so i'll take
no lectures from this prime minister
he lacks the seriousness and gravity uh
for the moment and i would ask the prime
minister to apologize for his words that
are deeply insulting but to the people
of ukraine and absolutely ridiculous
about the labour party